now bet you're waking up this morning
the way a lot of us are still in shock
and still can't really wrap our brains
around what happened to Kobe Bryant
yesterday and his 13 year old daughter
who died in that chopper crash when I
first heard the news yesterday my son
sent me a text said he'd heard it
reported on TMZ I said that can't be
true because no one else was reporting
it so you kept hoping against hope that
it was wrong and of course it turned out
to be very very accurate very very sad
yesterday it's the heart one of the
hardest things for me has been looking
at the pictures of Kobe and their
daughter yeah courtside so many of them
they're just I mean it's just my wife
said you said can't look at them anymore
I know I know we're all still crying
today thinking about that news and
that's where we began because the
tributes are pouring in from around the
world to Kobe Bryant he was as you know
an American icon whose cultural impact
really goes far beyond the NBA Bryant
and his 13 year old daughter Gianna and
seven other people were killed yesterday
when their helicopter crashed in
California so this news brought a
massive crowd of people to the Staples
Center and they are still there where
Bryant led the Los Angeles Lakers to
five NBA titles the tributes continued
inside at last night's Grammy Awards
from host Alicia Keys she called it the
house at Kobe Belt she's right and other
performers on Twitter former teammate
Shaquille O'Neal said Bryant was so much
more than an athlete
while Lakers legend Magic Johnson called
him a mentor to both male and female
players President Trump tweeted he loved
his family so much and had such strong
passion for the future and former
President Obama said Bryant was just
getting started in what would have been
just as meaningful a second act we begin
our coverage with Jonathan Vigliotti who
is near the scene of the crash in
Calabasas northwest of downtown Los
Angeles Jonathan what do we know so far
about this investigation Anthony I spoke
with several witnesses who say the fog
was so thick at the time of this crash
they couldn't actually see the
helicopter but they could feel it and
hear it they said it was flying solo it
caused many of the buildings here to
vibrate what ultimately causes crash is
still part of this ongoing investigation
the NTSB is expected here on the scene
later this morning and they do have
their work
cut out for them the crash site is
incredibly steep and there was a
magnesium fire that was sparked
immediately after this crash that we are
told destroyed much of the evidence this
is worldwide isn't just Los Angeles
we're all hurting it's a world of pain
or no he meant happiness basketball
legend Kobe Bryant wasn't just one of
the greatest to play the game he was
admired by people around the world for
his actions off the court as much as
when he was on it God you've got a good
one introduced in the Black Mamba Kobe
bean Brian the retired NBA star was
killed after his personal helicopter
crashed into a steep hillside Sunday
morning killing everybody on board
including his 13 year old daughter
Gianna as you can imagine it's a
logistical nightmare in a sense because
a crash site itself is not easily
accessible debris from the charred
helicopter was scattered across the size
of a football field the helicopter was
flying in fog that was so thick the LAPD
had grounded its helicopter fleet Sunday
morning I think he was just completely
disoriented he couldn't see Scott de
leurs told us he heard the chopper going
down and called 9-1-1 it just slowly
moved over here turning a track right
towards that building and the impact I
counted maybe 20 25 seconds from the
time it was vertical above me in it and
then I heard the impact about 25 seconds
later bryant his daughter and seven
other people were on their way to his
Mamba Cup tournament a Boys and Girls
youth basketball league Bryant found it
after he retired Bryant was to coach his
daughter
Jionni's team among the victims
identified on the helicopter Orange
Coast College baseball coach John
Altobelli
his wife Kerry and daughter Alisa Sarah
Chester and her daughter Payton who was
a teammate of Gianna Bryant's and the
pilot
aras Obion along with the girl's
assistant coach Christina Mouser the
retired Lakers shooting guard often
called his daughter Gianna mamacita
after his own court nicknamed Black
Mamba de fired up about it we'll have a
good time and like her father she
inherited his love of basketball and
hope to one day play in the W
I'm still in charge and still can't
believe
we spoke to a group of players who
participated in the Mamba tournament two
people I wanted to encourage it when I
arrived here at the scene yesterday
morning there were already hundreds of
fans that were gathered here
collectively morning I spoke with one of
them who said when we lose a hero we
gain a sense of our own mortality
and on that note I want to bring in our
National Transportation correspondent
Kris Van Cleave who's following the
investigation Kris what are we learning
well good morning John the pilot was in
touch with air traffic controllers we
know him to be a experienced pilot but
so far there are no reports of any kind
of distress call
at least at this point now the
helicopter was a sikorsky s-76 that is a
respected well known high-end helicopter
with a good safety record the chopper
circled Glendale for about 12 minutes
before continuing on under special
visual flight rules a pilot requesting
special VFR is taking on some added risk
because they are opting to fly at a
lower altitude and at lower visibility
than under normal circumstances that
decision to continue this flight instead
of waiting out the weather is going to
be closely scrutinized remember this
pilot had eight passengers on board and
was flying towards hills that would
require the chopper to gain altitude
despite low level clouds and fog now at
one point air traffic controllers can be
heard telling the pilot he's too low
that was in response to the pilots
request for ATC to follow his flight
path on radar it does not appear at this
point that controllers were telling the
pilot he was flying too low for the
surrounding terrain once the NTSB gets
here on scene they're gonna be looking
for any sign of mechanical failure or
anything else that could have been
brought that could have factored into
bringing this helicopter down Tony all
right Chris a lot of questions about
that fog this morning thank you very
much